many of us have hundreds of things on
our minds at any moment
often struggling to keep track of
everything we need to do
but fortunately there's one important
thing we don't have to worry about
remembering
breathing when you breathe you transport
oxygen to the body's cells to keep them
working
and clear your system of the carbon
dioxide that this work
generates breathing in other words keeps
the body alive
so how do we accomplish this crucial and
complex task
without even thinking about it the
answer lies in our body's respiratory
system
like any machinery it consists of
specialized components
and requires a trigger to start
functioning here the components are the
structures and tissues
making up the lungs as well as the
various other respiratory organs
connected to them
and to get this machine moving we need
the autonomic nervous system
our brain's unconscious control center
for the vital functions
as the body prepares to take in
oxygen-rich air
this system sends a signal to the
muscles around your lungs
flattening the diaphragm and contracting
the intercostal muscles between your
ribs
to create more space for the lungs to
expand
air then whooshes into your nose and
mouth through your trachea
and into the bronchi that's split at the
trachea's base
with one entering each lung like tree
branches
these small tubes divide into thousands
of tinier passages
called bronchioles it's tempting to
think of the lungs as huge balloons
but instead of being hollow they're
actually spongy inside
with the bronchioles running throughout
the parenchyma tissue
at the end of each bronchiole is a
little air sac
called an alveolus wrapped in
capillaries full of red blood cells
containing special proteins called
hemoglobin
the air you've breathed in fills these
sacks causing the lungs to inflate
here is where the vital exchange occurs
at this point
the capillaries are packed with carbon
dioxide and the air sacs are full of
oxygen
but due to the basic process of
diffusion the molecules of each gas
want to move to a place where there is a
lower concentration of their kind
so as oxygen crosses over to the
capillaries the hemoglobin grabs it up
while the carbon dioxide is unloaded
into the lungs the oxygen-rich
hemoglobin is then transported
throughout the body
via the bloodstream but what do our
lungs do with all that carbon dioxide
exhale it of course the autonomic
nervous system kicks in
again causing the diaphragm to ball up
and the intercostal muscles to relax
making the chest cavities smaller and
forcing the lungs to compress
the carbon dioxide rich air is expelled
and the cycle begins again
so that's how these spongy organs keep
our bodies efficiently supplied with air
lungs inhale and exhale between 15 and
25 times a minute
which amounts to an incredible 10 000
liters of air
each day that's a lot of work but don't
sweat it
your lungs and your autonomic nervous
system have got it covered
you